روحا طيب حضرتك بدات تتحدث عن الحياه في
روسيا الى اي مدى غيرت الحرب الحياه
بعد ان قيل في بدايه الحرب انه سيتم عزل
روسيا رقميا على الاقل بتعرف نظام سويفت
لا يتم التعامل في به في روسيا الم يعقد
هذا حياه المواطنين الروس
الى حد كبير لم يؤثر مثلا فيما خصوص السفر
باتمان الصعب الان على اي شخص
ان يسافر من الغرب اوروبا او الولايات
المتحده للدخول الى روسيا فعاليه ان
يسافر الى دوله اخرى مثلا دبي واسطنبول
ومن هناك الدخول الى روسيا وهذا يعني بان
الروس الذين اعتادوا على قضاء العطلات
مثلا في الدول المتوسط باتت خياراتهم الان
بين تركيا ودول الخليج العربي او ربما
الان بعض الدول اسيا فهنالك بعض القيود في
هذا الخصوص ولكن علينا ان نتذكر
ان الشعب الروسي وغالبيه الشعب الروسي
يعتمدون بشكل اكبر على الخدمات المحليه
والبضائع والمنتجات المحليه روسيا لديها
اكتفاء ذاتي مثلا في المنتجات الغذائيه
نتحدث عن ذلك على انه احدى فوائد العقوبات
على سبيل المثال خلال العوامل الثمانيه
الماضيه في عام 2013 كانت رسلت
ثلثي المواد الغذائي الاستهلاكيه وبسب
العقوبات للعوام الثمانيه الماضيه لم يعد
لديها فقط اكتفاء ذاتي بل باتت من الدول
المصدره للمواد الغذائيه ولذلك فان الشعب
تاثر بشكل اقل بكثير في حياتهم اليوميه
وحتى الانترنت
رقميا فهنالك بعض القيود ولكن في الحقيقه
مع
استخدامي حتى خدمات الفي بي ان الاساسيه
في امكانهم متابعه القنوات المحظوره
او التي حضرت على روسيا فمن الصعب القول
انه هنالك عرقله كبيره ولكن بالتاكيد مع
كل عمليات الحشد والشباب الذين
الاكثر سيطلب منهم الخدمه العسكريه وحتى
جيش الاحتياطي فهذا سبب عرقله كبيره عرقله
اجتماعيه
احتماليه نداءهم واستدعاهم للخدمه
العسكريه
فالى الان
الاثار كانت محدوده الشخصيه عده مرات خلال
عمل ماضي بعض المنتجات ربما التي يستخدمها
منتجات استهلاكيه اختفت لفتره ربما لبضعه
اشهر لان الشركات اغلق المكاتبه ولكنها
عاده الظهور
تحت مخطط يسمى بالاستيراد المتوازي
فالشركات الغربيه لمعاده
السوق الروسي